ladies gentlemen in mainz
[Musik]
wir haben uns hier heute versammelt
meine lieben freunde da germany's next
topmodel
meine lieblings fernsehen sendung die
models der diesjährigen staffel
germany's next topmodel der hier in
einer woche losgeht wurde nun auf der
website hier vergisst er sich die
freunde von sam mendes ist ja schon
schlimm genug dass der jedes video von
mir cloud also wirklich jedes video
jetzt ist seine freunde noch bei gntm
ist sie nicht auch eigentlich
amerikanerin kayla egal wie es von
münchen burg möchte ich heute auf jeden
fall auf die suche nach seinem favoriten
ich habe mich ja auch schon extra in
schale geworfen
fashion icon also das hier ist die seite
wo die models vorgestellt werden als
erstes können wir uns ja mal wirklich
die enisa hier anschauen
da direkt ein video hier zu haben
hallo macht die kacke mal aus in dieser
alter 24 berufen
ich mache mit meinem freund teilen des
youtube-videos
ich glaube es hat sich da jemand
vorgestellt und mein freund ist ist
bekannt genug dass das gibt's menschen
das wild das nutzen und dafür muss man
auch also immer aber ich habe kein wort
verstanden also das ist auf jeden fall
die enisa ihm die freundin von dem namen
des stars scheint ihr nächstes hier sind
auch noch mal ein paar bilder
da sollte was
hier unten sind dann noch so ein paar
polaroidfotos die geshootet wurde und
das ist elisa wenn man direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten modell theresia das hier
ist die theresia sie stetig alter 26
beruf freiberuflerinnen mein verlobter
ist 27 jahre älter als
hey sagt mal einsatz um dich zu
beschreiben das hier sind die fotos von
der theresia die chance das muss man so
sagen die sieht jetzt nicht aus wenn sie
26 sondern wirklich so als wäre sie 18
das verstehe ich wirklich nicht warum
die hier so bilder gemacht haben in acht
von zehn fällen sind antibiotika gegen
halsschmerzen wirkungslos h ok will ich
danke ich hab das lächeln öffnet einfach
die tür ganz kurz das hat mich gerade so
mäßig hier geschnitten das war die dtm
redaktion selbst ist jetzt normal sehen
halte real weiter mit nissen model jewel
das hier ist die jam sie ist 23 jahre
alt handelsfachwirt/in also die erste
wirklich mit einem richtigen beruf ich
möchte für chanel laufen ja wie geht er
mit recht geringen erwartungen in die
staffel vor wir uns das video hier von
der del anschauen er möchte noch mal
ganz kurz das sagen was ich in jeder
reaktion auf einem kanal ja sagen wenn
ich irgendwie bei eine person lache oder
einen witz machen oder so das ist alles
nur ironisch und das geht nicht gegen
die person persönlich also das ist alles
mit einem gewissen ansatz von humor zu
verstehen merkt man ja auch schon daran
wie ich hier
angel
die sympathisch alle anderen das auch
ein ja ich finde auch personen muss man
mit einem lächeln zu gehen und mein
freund ist ja so bekannt aber die sagt
einfach herr ich habe eigentlich vier
namen jean pascal krieger aber reicht
vollkommen aus
richtig sympathisch das erinnert mich so
ein bisschen in die claudia mit k aus
der letzten staffel allerdings ist mir
die duell hier wirklich schon die
sympathischen kandidaten und ich hoffe
dass die weit kommt ich glaube sie wird
auch so der publikumsliebling seine mir
klicken aber mal direkt auf nächstes
model sarah ich will das hier nicht
sehen die sarah ist erst 20 jahre alt
sie ist von beruf schon model also das
wird interessant und ihr ersatz ist es
wird schwer meine mutter los zu lassen
bis 20 bis jetzt nicht 16 ich glaube die
sarah wird sehr weit kommen die können
schon ins finale kommen weil die einfach
schon ein bisschen erfahrung hat melina
die medien als 18 jahre als die
studentin und sie hat kein problem damit
wenn ihre langen haare abkommen
das hier sind ihre bilder also es ist
bisher die jüngste kandidatin die ich
mir angeschaut habe ich bin jünger
ich bin 18 jahre alt ich komme aus
duisburg dass die nordrhein westfalen
mit viel spannung und wünschen dir auf
dem weg das war so als ändern kamera
hinter der kamera und zettel hoch
gehalten hat und es tut mir ja merlin
allerdings jr news ich glaube die ist
die sie haben sehr interessanten
charakter der aber auch manchmal anecken
kann also das ist auf jeden fall die
melina hat so ein bisschen exotischen
flair on ice und niedere schokoladen
papierverpackungen aber sie hat auf
jeden fall ein sehr sehr guten körper
das sieht man hier schon raus aber ich
habe die medien damit auch weit kommen
caroline das hier ist die liebe caroline
die karoline ist 21 jahre alt studentin
und vor der kamera zu posen fällt mir
unheimlich leicht mensch herzlichen
glückwunsch du bist ja schon direkt das
topmodel normalerweise geht er mit
seiner aussage rainha model macht mir
spaß und wenn es sein soll dann werde
ich halt topmodel
nicht als frau nicht schlimm ich glaube
die caro wird direkt zu beginn
rausfliegen wird gegen dich caro falls
dieser zeit sehen sollte dabei auch ganz
lustig bei meiner reaktion auf die em
2018 jeder irgendwie hat meinen reaction
gesehen als du dann beim finale da waren
und bei der after show das war ganz
peinlich für mich ich laufe da so lange
und da kam halt nach und nach die ganzen
mädels an ob sie ist ja damals reagiert
habe und mich darüber lustig gemacht
haben und hoffentlich wollt ihr mich
jetzt nicht umbringen also diebe caro
falls du das hier sehen sollte ist es
überhaupt nicht böse gemeint du bist ein
ganz ganz süßes mädchen aber ich glaube
du wirst bei germany's next topmodel
nicht weit kommen weil das gewisse extra
glaube ich fehlt selina wie selina hat
hier ein silbernes kleid am das ein
wenig so aussieht wie eine alufolie
sie ist 22 jahre alte studentin und ihr
satz ist ich war ein halbes jahr alleine
in australien
coole nach australien und bin alleine
film halb ist ja eben gereist hat mir
dort ein auto gekauft also das ist jetzt
sicher das was irgendwie jeder zweite
deutsche macht es ist jetzt nicht weiß
was ich da in die dings schreibt führte
dass ich noch mal ganz kurz eben sagen
wollte ist
ich habe euch und in der beschreibung
eine andere reaktion auf die gntm
kandidatinnen von links und zwar von der
lieben annika die ein bisschen mehr
ahnung davon hat und das ganze auch ein
bisschen ernster gemacht hat aber
trotzdem sehr lustig also schaute auch
gern mal vorbei deborah die bohrer ist
22 jahre alt ihr beruf ist händlerin und
sie sagte von professioneller
tänzerinnen zum top model m so sieht sie
aus also ich glaube wirklich dass sie
ins finale kommen wird weil sie einfach
sollen charakter mitbringt das sieht man
hier schon auf den bildern die anderen
stehen da einfach nur ein lächeln und
sie macht was auch wenn sie knetet auch
eigentlich einfach nur als auch nicht so
einzigartig dass meine ich einfach
wieder so ein witziger charakter her ich
habe gerade banane gegessen sind meine
ziele noch sauber die seele des 19 jahre
alt sie ist von beruf eine
tiermedizinische fachangestellte und ihr
satz ist früher fand ich mich nicht
schön
ja das blöd so sieht die ziellinie aus
ich finde
genau so stellt man sich eine
tiermedizinische fachangestellte vor wie
sieht wirklich aus als als wer sie
sonnen unfassbar lieber mensch und
kümmert sich um tiere ich habe eine
ausbildung abgeschlossen zur
tiermedizinischen fachangestellten mir
kommt es so vor als wäre diese linien
die einzige die so einen richtigen plan
hat ist abzuwarten ob das bei gntm was
wird das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen
obwohl ich bin erlebt hier vonnöten
burgfest die conti- manager von graf
vanessa nichts gegen dich fern es aber
ich finde den namen
ich finde es verbindet man mit so einem
streber mädchen die alle verpetzt ise
vanessa hier ist aber auf jeden fall 21
jahre alte sie ist von beruf ebenfalls
schon model und ich habe schon viele
fashion weeks mitgemacht ich habe auch
schon mal eine fashion week mitgemacht
war da aber nur bei drei shows weil die
alle drei so richtig geile kleine snacks
hatten deshalb ein ganz anderes thema im
duster auf jeden fall die vanessa sie
läuft hier auch in
also outfit hin oder her man merkt schon
dass die ahnung hat wie man läuft und
wie man sich präsentiert
ich glaube das will keiner der damit
macht es ich bin ganz ehrlich wenn ich
mir die vanessa hier so anschaue dann
würde ich auf den ersten sieg denken ja
ist ein hübsches mädel aber jetzt nicht
ja vielleicht doch ein model also sie
weiß schon wie sie alles einsetzt was
sie hat bin ich gespannt ob das für
germany's next topmodel reich wie gesagt
es kann nur eine werden kim possible ist
die nächste so sieht die kim aus also
sie hat auch einen sehr schönen körper
sie ist 18 jahre alt angehende
bwl-studentin
das heißt sie ist noch nicht studenten
ich bin angehende astronaut aber auch
noch nicht astronaut ich wollte endlich
fraulich aussehen
was genau haben einfach so möwen rum da
ich selber viele vorbilder habe und
viele größte partei
sie schon hübsch
hagen ich halt wieder
hey ich will bwl studieren blabla muss
man das maul
das ist auf jeden fall die kim possible
da bin ich mir auch ziemlich sicher dass
sie weit kommen wird aber ist in meinen
augen zum standard kandidat der
vielleicht an einigen ecken ein bisschen
beef haben wird aber prinzipiell eher im
hintergrund agieren wird henry nah wie
viele kandidatinnen haben wir ja
eigentlich noch welchen slater
noch 30 also ich würde ja gern auf alle
kandidatinnen heute reagieren aber leute
die fashion-ikone brauchen auch mal eine
pause von daher würde ich an der
jetzigen stelle das heutige video auch
beenden bei der lieben freude wenn ihr
wollt dass ich in einigen tagen einen
zweiten teil von meiner reaktion auf
germany's next topmodel -kandidatinnen
hier auf meinem kanal hochladen dann
lass deinen glauben hoch bei diesem
video dabei 60.000 lights ich weiß ist
der menge aber wenn ihr 60.000 likes
schaffen sollte dann kommt in einigen
tagen der zweite teil in dem ich auf die
restlichen kandidatinnen reagiere also
gebt dem video einen daumen hoch wenn
ihr einen zweiten teil haben wollte er
schreibt mir gern schon mal euren
favoriten für germany's next topmodel
2009 10 und die kommentare und abonniert
man den kanal
[Musik]
ein